hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to as you
can probably tell by my voice I'm just
getting over an illness it was either
brought on by natural circumstances or
the film I saw was so bad it made me
physically sick either one one surprised
me so the doctor says I should be fine
though as long as I get plenty of rest
and relaxation
oh who don't you know the cure for
anything anywhere is laughter who-who
are you
I'm doctor bitch spasms and I'm here to
make you laugh oh but I don't want to
laugh I want to get better huh laughter
is the best medicine no medicines the
des medicine Oh what you don't trust a
doctor who looks like this no I don't
look the right nose it's funny no it
isn't it's funny
no it isn't it's funny no it isn't it's
funny no it isn't it's funny no it isn't
oh it's patch Adams everybody
I know what you're thinking Oh nostalgia
critic Europeans new forms of medicine
and new techniques no I'm not I'm
against a bad rabble blames movie
horribly relating that new form of
medicine and new techniques I personally
don't know the techniques of the real
Hunter Adams work maybe they do maybe
he's a genius
from what I've looked up he seems pretty
legit but the way they're trying to tell
his story is such a cliched emotionally
forced dick fest it makes me want to
kick him in his comedic dangly red balls
so let's see how much based on a real
story can get away with this is patch
Adams so how is the raunchy Williams
going to make his entrance in this film
oh wait is this the actually funny Robin
Williams or the shoving inspiration down
your throat until you puke rebel leaves
cue the piano we see patch checking
himself into a mental institution
because he's suicidal now is it me or
would they put the suicidal prison in a
less threatening holy shit I want to
shoot myself location than this yeah I'd
be afraid of a future King reunion - I
don't know even for 1969 when they know
not to put a person who's for the most
part calm enough sound mind
you know Ward filled with screaming
unstable people well maybe they're not
unstable maybe they're just
misunderstood Oh Pat show us the way I
think here's a question you find that
funny hunter making fun of a man's
infirmity maybe he does have a question
he's alive he's catatonic
he still has a brain maybe he wants to
participate too maybe beanie knows a lot
more than we give him credit for yeah
that's true maybe we should treat him
like a person instead just some useless
punchline how much taller is Wilt
Chamberlain than you I say hello to
Hitler ha ha who'd win a staring contest
beating who likes to masturbate yeah our
healer everybody when he's not done
making fun of what's wrong with you he
goes down to the orphanage to mock the
kids with no parents
oh wait wait that's right Adams is the
hero because the big bad establishment
doesn't want people laughing woman
Rumble this is most unorthodox ooh never
leave India Shane poor hmm idiot he also
befriends a brilliant mind that went
crazy a few years ago but of course
patch connects with it
how many do you see there four fingers
anything no no look at me you're
focusing on the problem you focus on the
problem you can't see the solution never
focus on the problem look at me now
that's a good point
in fact most of the time I don't even
want to know what the problem is I just
want to focus on the solution nostalgia
critic there's another bot don't tell me
the problem I only want to focus on the
solution I see a banana use of the net
Oh bananas gonna put out a fire as it is
but I don't think one of the
establishments know then you still
banana you see you didn't believe that
the manna we work at that's why you're
on fire look beyond the fingers how many
do you see
he needs a good answer and see what no
one else sees see what everyone else
chooses not to see I feel conformity
laziness Wow how inspiring that's the
most original message I've ever heard in
a Ravel lanes movie since good morning
Vietnam Dead Poets Society Fisher King
Jack Good Will Hunting being human Jacob
the liar flubber Bicentennial man and
man of the year but I'm sure this Robin
Lane's movie has a totally different
spin on it
so he sees that by acting goofy with the
patients he can bring himself to their
level and help cure their fears so he
decides he wants to leave and help
people I'm leaving I want to learn about
people I want to help them with their
troubles that's what I do but you suck
at it I'm a bit of a most unorthodox
tolaram I want to listen I'm gonna
really listen to people wonderful I'm
sure you'll be a wonderful psychiatrist
or a medical doctor I guess they're
practically the same thing
so he finds the best spot to inspiringly
Rebell as he meets up with his new
roommate I don't mean to be rude but
aren't you a little old to be starting
medical school patch Adams
Mitch Roman Georgetown University I was
awarded the William F Thompson
scientific achievement award I wants to
a picture of a rabbit that got me two
gold stars hmm I hope you in no way
emotionally changed me by the end of
this film but there's even more of the
evil establishment to battle like the
evil doctor who tries to teach everybody
to never get emotionally involved with
their patients he trusts you the way a
child trusts he trusts you to do no harm
I'm sure she's not the love interest
human beings are not worthy of trust it
is our mission here rigorously and
ruthlessly train the humanity out of you
and make you into something better we're
gonna make doctors out of you mercy is
for the weak here on the street in
competition a man confronts you he's the
enemy
an enemy deserves no mercy
so patch tries to make a move on the
obvious love interest but sadly like
most of the people in this movie her
dialog is nothing but a walking
character introduction for the trailer
lesbian ballbuster airhead leach
whichever one of these disgust you the
most take your pick
oh please pass the word I'm not here to
date I am NOT here to flirt I'm here to
study okay remember in my haunting
review how I said the 90s had a certain
way of writing homosexuals well they had
a certain way of writing women to women
in the media for so long were always the
emotional support the damsels the
smiling pretty faces so in the 90s there
was a desperate need to change that well
not by making them a pretty adept fuck
we wouldn't do that but we suddenly made
them cold bitter confrontational and
overly strong to go out of the way to
show that they're not those old
emotional stereotypes and instead make
way for new emotional stereotypes where
you see in every 90s film the woman
behind this strong independent wall that
won't let anybody in he's a sad little
bunny rabbit that will eventually let
down her defenses and reveal a tragic
backstory so you see she wasn't a strong
confident worker just because she was a
strong confident worker dick doe she
just wants to be him like any other
fragile woman oh I don't want to think I
just want to be loved so patch wants to
lower her defenses and get through to
her insecurities even though he's
clearly the king of masking insecurity
himself but we want to lower his
defenses because he makes us laugh and
that excuses everything in this movie
and I'm not kidding look at his
rationale of acting like a jackass in
medical school the goal be to break
through program response to changing
normal parameters and getting a new
emotional response from the person
hello I don't get it I is a programmed
response I reached her you scared her
now wait wait for it
Oh
laughs
oh yeah that's a rational response and
not some contrived screenwriting device
oh oh you see I connected with you know
you did you hit me in the face
wait for it you know I'm really
regretting raining this character so for
whatever reason we get a weird segue
where patch and his friends convince a
guy that they're part of a meat
packaging convention yeah you heard
right a meat packaging convention no New
Zealand they found a whole new use for
sheep what's that wool oh yeah I can
clearly see that this movie is going to
represent people in an accurate and
realistic manner no stereotypes are
manipulative portrayals here this movies
like watching real-life proud of my meat
I know you're proud of your me whip it
zip it and send it out all right so we
spent three damn minutes in this place
just to realize what that if he wears a
doctor's coat he can fool people into
thinking he's a three year student okay
movie did you just make a bet that you
could somehow work a meat packaging
convention scene in there somehow here
we have a juvenile onset diabetic with
poor circulation and diabetic neuropathy
as you can see these are diabetic ulcers
with lymphedema and evidence of gangrene
consider antibiotics possibly amputation
what's her name
oh yeah I was just wondering the
patient's name
Marjorie hi Marjorie Hey all right are
you telling me that years and years of
medical research and we never put
together until the early 70s that
there's a difference between not being
emotionally evolved and not being a dick
who would talk that way in front of a
patient even back then
it's called bedside manner that existed
before patch Adams I mean this kind of
misrepresentation is just giving him all
the more reason to do stupid things like
oh I was in a mental ward can you tell
Oh
awesome wonderful I mean that's really
really great work be a clown I mean
you're clearly not doing anything here
representing a doctor go to hospitals
and cheer people up that's fine
I have no problem but I'm sorry if
choosing my doctors comes between this
stabilize the blood sugar consider
antibiotics possibly amputation and this
I'm choosing the amputate guy I don't
trust him with a saw but the big bad
establishment won't let him have any
Ford let's take him to a darkly lit room
where shadows are casted on his face
bullying on the lovely rock truth of it
is hunter passion doesn't make doctors I
make doctors but don't you think of our
way of doing things is a product of
centuries of experience it's my hospital
first we will heal patients and then the
world but the doctors cold-heartedness
does not fit well with the charming
rebel 1432 deviation of atomic I think
we'd learn more if we were working
closely with patients I thought that's
why we're here studying to learn enough
to help the patients yes that is right
pedaling don't waste your breath don't
you if he does that again you can shoot
him don't you think I see through you
you act like you're above the system
when you're really just a nonconformist
too you have to get under the
fingernails of any authority figure that
crosses your path is the way I'm dealing
with cement security please hand over
the rest of the movie to her clearly she
should be the focus listen can we get
back to the tunnel please what if a
doctor becomes emotionally involved with
the patient what is wrong with that does
a doctor explode no you know what I'm
good you know I'm gonna take that scene
I'm gonna put it away and I'm going to
save it for later
because trust me that scene is really
gonna stab this movie in the ass later
no no it's okay you'll get your chance
no no no don't touch anything out there
no no no don't text
bat scene that's a bat bat scene
selecting cooky to entertain patients is
one thing but fucking patch wants to ads
I get asked full time so he goes around
to all the students who are not sick and
annoys the living shit out of them even
when they're in the middle of taking a
test Donner Party of 50 hotner Donner
Party over hair you know if I stab you
will you promise me that you will not
only die but it will hurt
he also sneaks into patients rooms and
surprises them with balloon animals
I sure hope none of them are susceptible
to heart attacks
fish
oh and thank God sleep isn't important
to any of the other patients in this
ward it's not like they put them in
those beds overnight to get rest no no
it's to watch people have mental
breakdowns with balloon animal safaris
this is my way of telling you you have
cancer what about you dear what's your
fantasy I've always wanted to be in a
swimming pool full of noodles or to wall
and tap the body and entire pool full of
noodles look up Japanese porn I'm sure
you'll find something but get ready to
get pissed off even more he's actually
one of the highest testing students in
the school yeah what the hell we've
never seen him study in this film or do
anything resembling schoolwork or hell
even doctor work all he does is act like
he's from a mental ward oh wait he wants
from a mental ward
you told Walcott I cheated look cut the
crap hunter I live with you I know how
much you study or I should say don't
study and you do better than me give me
a break
okay this is a good point why don't we
see him study in Amadeus they at least
point out that he was raised from
childhood to be obsessed with music
that's how he can remember things so
well but nothing here ever gives us a
clue as to why he never studies and yet
gets good grades for all we know he
could be cheating they never give us
another explanation but apparently the
teacher trusts him enough to handle the
welcoming committee for a group of
visiting gynecologists this year I have
chosen Adams hunter there's a detailed
list of instructions in my office oh and
the auditorium could use a good cleaning
ah yeah tell me professor how did you
come to that brilliant logical
conclusion I'm sure absolutely nothing
will go wrong and no committee
possibilities will come from this whoa
welcome cold handed ones Zach morass
it's an honor to greet / welcome so many
who have touched so many women in such a
powerful way the orthodoxy levels on
this our most honor
so finally and I mean finally he gets
himself expelled chopped I can't imagine
why
kindly remove your things that vacate to
school premises as soon as possible but
for for asking a group of doctors to
have a sense of humor about themselves
no that wasn't asking that was forcing
as a comedian you should know the
difference back loud why am i such a
threat to you sir because what you want
is for us to get down there on the same
level as our patients we are not on the
same level as them we are healthy so he
goes to the Dean of Medicine and like a
doofus he actually lets him back in
that's good it means he can have an
emotional death scene with one of the
patients
that's right out family out out you're
not allowed in here while your dad's on
his deathbed only patch is allowed to
have an emotional scene with him here
it's so silly for thinking you can do do
I see blue bird singing a song I am so
glad the family wasn't there to witness
that I mean shaking the head and the
thumping it against the pillow no child
should ever have to see such a horrible
performance so seeing this somehow gets
him thinking about how many people don't
have health insurance so he starts its
own Hospital in a house to practice
medicine without a license and start
seeing patients for free okay nice
thought but get your fucking license I
mean go god that's horrible that's
almost as bad it's stealing from a
hospital I've been trying to warn you
guys about this for weeks and now we
have absolutely zero supplies I need
your feet please crushing movie did you
even save this part out loud your hero
is stealing from a hospital do you think
that would sound good on a movie poster
patch Adams he steals from hospitals I
wouldn't see that Oh Oh God find out
about our borrowed supplies no borrowing
implies you asked asshole they also
decide they don't need any pass history
on any of these patients so scary people
like this are allowed in I thought maybe
I'd get some you know maybe I talked to
somebody because my thoughts remember
this scene also look at you look at you
but first let's bring up that inevitable
tragic backstory we were talking about
earlier my entire life men have been
attracted to me my entire life
oh well um do you know the best cure for
that is a monkey Oh laughter specific
life just as massive whoa I was molested
although he touched me there doctor are
you feeling better feel better ha ha ha
ha when I was a little girl I would look
out my bedroom window with caterpillars
turn into these beautiful creatures that
could fly away completely untouched so
much you'd imagine she finally gives
into patches charm discovering that she
can trust not only people but met again
just at the time when the crazy man from
before claims he needs help from her uh
come in I really can't stay very long I
just wanted to see how you were doing no
we don't want to be late
pretend Fisher was murdered she was with
Lara what's over the shotgun involved
and he turned the gun on himself
whoa holy smokes
she died in real life it's horrible
can't even make a joke about that I mean
a woman was murdered like that probably
in bad taste right I mean it's okay I
feel so bad about what I said earlier
hey uh I don't know what I can or can't
get away with now this is really
sensitive territory holy shit I gotta do
more research on this I I got find out
all the details yeah maybe she was
Melissa May she did go through all that
horrible stuff or maybe she was a man
who was not romantically interested in
patch at all in fact the female
character was a complete work of fiction
in this movie
okay movie come here come here movie
come here you're gentle with my movie oh
okay
all bets are off if this movie can't
even represent a dead person by getting
his gender right not making up a false
romance and child molesting story all of
it fabricated I'm sorry I've worked my
way up to this joke remember that scene
I brought up earlier what if a doctor
becomes emotionally involved with the
patient what is wrong with that does a
doctor explode well if you count bullets
blowing up the head of your fictional
dead girlfriend yes yes they fuck I know
I mean I know a person really was
murdered in real life but it wasn't the
same way it wasn't the same time and it
wasn't even the same gender as they're
saying here and what is so strange about
this is that it totally proves why the
method they're so poorly trying to
convey to us wouldn't work people do
make bad choices when they're emotional
and bad things do happen again
the real teachings of the real hunter
Adams are much smarter than this and by
trying to simplify it to such a
disgusting fictionalized degree is
absolutely horrible let me tell you
something movie maybe you should have
been emotionally invested when you were
representing the life of a man he
theories his friends his real life
practices and his actual card work fuck
so after getting torn up about his never
existing girlfriend being killed he once
again contemplates suicide but get a
load of this a butterfly flies up to it
Oh could it be his dead girlfriend
well I guess it is seeing how the
vomit-inducing happy music is playing
louder than a full house episode I guess
this means you can go back and start
working with patients again including
getting that crazy lady for swimming
pool full of noodles this calls for that
whimsical Robin Williams yell that can
only be played over sappy emotional
music
my story or gist of bullied
what a beanbag establishment wants to
shut him down again did we just go
through this scene that our standards
and codes you make the patients and
everyone else around you uncomfortable I
make you uncomfortable is clear you have
Orthodox on Orthodox and then Donaldson
art this of course leads to a car room
scene where patch makes what his tenth
big emotional speech did you consider
the ramifications of your actions what
if one of your patients had died
what's wrong with death sir did a man
who wants to save lives really just say
that
why can't we treat death with a certain
amount of humanity and dignity and
decency and God forbid maybe even humor
I know I had a good laugh with my
non-existent girlfriend croaked he keeps
making his speech and I swear to God he
uses all these cliched lies as God is my
witness as God is my witness then I'm
guilty as charged and I am guilty as
charged I've lost everything but also
gained everything I've lost everything
but I've also gained everything you
can't control my spirit you can't
control my spirit and the best damn
doctor the world has ever seen the best
damn doctor the world has ever seen oh
wait you forgot uh you complete me and
love means never having to say you're
sorry and I know what you're thinking
could this possibly get any more
ridiculously sappy well not only do all
the sick kids come in at the end kind of
weird they weren't there at the
beginning but they all wait until they
get inside to put on their big red noses
this is all I can do now I have no words
this is the only representation I can
give feed on it feed on it steady Fester
they get it sink into your contrived
manipulated haleyss we find your methods
less than appealing your appearance and
your demeanor do not reflect what we
believe is necessary to earn the
patient's trust and respect yeah however
you openly accuse us of adhering to
time-honored practice yes it however is
have been the backbone however however
however however yeah by no fault and
your attempts to improve the quality of
life around you therefore we find no
merit in the decision to block your
graduation from medical school and Dean
Walker in the future I think matters
like this could best be solved if you
yourself would practice a little
excessive happiness
well I'm happy to see you finally
decided to conform more than you know
dr. Adams everybody he'll see you on
your deathbed which remember he doesn't
see as a big deal
people this movie is disgusting if you
want to talk about the benefits of
emotional interaction with your patients
fine if you want to talk about new forms
of practicing medicine and treating
people fine but do it as a fucking adult
not this childish poorly written
non-factual bullshit you know you do you
know don't watch the fictional bad patch
Adams watch the real factual patch Adams
I've looked him up his work is
fascinating and it goes beyond simply
jumping around like a jackass he's a
professional he takes his patients
seriously he works with each one
individually
every experience is different and he
works hard and wouldn't you know it he
didn't like this movie very much he said
it portrayed him as just a clown instead
of a hard-working doctor who did
practice medicine with a license did not
steal from a hospital and had a male
best friend who sadly lost his life and
was not just a cheap romantic foil when
you've had a fairly simple filming of
your life I personally took shorter than
you people still feel as
no but the guy you don't need to it's
hospital if you want just don't believe
anything in this shit fuck fuck shit
fuck home
you compartments don't you know that the
answer to anything is don't worry he's
not a via Korean character I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to
what's wrong with death sir